[Musique]
ce qu'il faut retenir des résultats
sportifs du week end dans le département
avec michael mier d'eurobonds soir en
soir grégory journaliste sport de la
rédaction de tv 78 on démarre une fois
n'est pas coutume par un résumé le match
avec du football auquel une partie à des
quarts de finale de coupe des yvelines
de football était programmé ce week-end
montigny-le-bretonneux recevait maurepas
match où il n'y a finalement pas eu
match les morts bazian se sent
facilement imposé 4 à 0 en contrôlant la
rencontre le résumé montigny le
bretonneux maurepas c'était l'une des
affiches de ces quarts de finale de
coupe des yvelines dès l'entamé du match
maurepas qui évolue en d1 de district
assume son statut de favori sa division
d'écart et montbazens se procurent les
meilleures occasions y arrive à marquer
deux fois 2 à 0 ce sera le score à la
pause ça se passe pas très bien on a
respecté les consignes du coach
après ils ont marqué sur une attaque
rapide et à
on se fait contrer ils ont une deuxième
au casque qui met au fond donc voilà
prend aussi de faire le nécessaire pour
revenir au déjà 2 1 après poussé pour
égaliser sur une tête juste garder la
possession c'est de faire ce qu'on a
fait en première mi-temps garde à vue un
système tranquillement le troisième va
venir sûrement tout seul ça va s'ouvrir
un peu plus espaces se livrer pour
sortir pour un premier roman avec le
premier pour nous titille un peu mais
vraiment sans le savoir le défenseur
tristan feely a vu juste quelques
minutes après la reprise ils coupent
belfodil réalise un petit numéro dans la
surface avant de marquer à 3 0 savage
arriva j'arrive à bien effacer finale
avec un petit piqué franchement c'est
j'ai bien aimé ce lama après je garde
tous et des buts
baup à bout un but un but pas encore
rassasié yacoub belfodil s'offre même un
triplé en fin de match meurent pas
l'emportent 4 à 0 c'est frustrant on se
fait éliminer
salma non bref pas grand chose à dire à
part que match de coupe on aurait dit
elle est peut-être un peu accru de la
femme étant entré dedans à l'envié on a
maîtrisé on savait que on savait qu'on
avait les qualités des voûtes défense
est fait aux français pour pouvoir faire
la différence si j'ai une division en
dessous ont conservé comporter avec un
petit avantage
après voilà maintenant on a su on a su
montré l'écart qui avait entraîné le
prochain tour de la coupe des yvelines
est programmée le dimanche 5 avril
on a bien apprécié amical lé but de
jakub belfodil bravo à lui et bravo à
l'équipe de maurepas on continue avec du
football américain
cette fois ci les templiers d'elancourt
en mode rouleau compresseur les élans
courtois n'ont pas fait de détail ce
samedi 22 février à domicile contre
leeds au coeur de nantes
les élans courtois l'emportent sur le
score de 51 à 0 après avoir dominé
l'ensemble de la partie à réaction c'est
une belle victoire
on a on a été plein partout autant en
défense qu'en attaque
franchement ça fait ça fait vraiment
plaisir de voir que mes coéquipiers
prennent du plaisir et du coup voilà on
a on a montré ce qu'on avait à montrer
maintenant certes on a fait beaucoup de
fautes mais on va apprendre de nos
erreurs et référent l'essayer sur nous
au classement les templiers d'elancourt
se replace cette troisième victoire en
quatre matches leur permet d'occuper la
deuxième place de leur poule derrière
les léopards de rouen les pf de fin de
saison sont donc accessibles ainsi
qu'une montée en première division c'est
un nos objectifs maintenant on en est
encore loin
là c'est plutôt en phase de playoffs on
pourra avoir une vraie indication sur
sûr sur cette question mais ça reste un
objectif maintenant c'est une marche est
très haute
encore beaucoup de beaucoup de travail
et pas mal de matches mais on va on va
pousser en fait au plus loin pour pour
atteindre cet objectif
prochain match pour les templiers
d'elancourt le 1er mars prochain sur le
terrain des diables rouges de villepinte
en attendant les éléments courtois
peuvent savourer grégory allez un
dernier résultat avec du rugby dans le
championnat de fédérale 2 plaisir s'est
incliné 38 à 13 sur le terrain de
beauvais ce week-end l'une des
meilleures équipes de la poule
au classement les plaisirs oies sont
toujours à la limite de la zone de
relégation avec un point d'avancé sur
orléans
merci michael la suite de l'actualité
sportive revinoise à retrouver dans
votre émission le 7-8 sport c'est après
ce journal